dionis du séjour se trouve sur punch
temps réel le niveau de la prison est
sorti c'est parti on vend en zonzon
usées bonjour les prisonniers alors déjà
déjà c'est plus correct sortir de la
prison et ne pas avoir un mauvais regard
tu es le début voilà alors là avec sa
part tient en cinq soldats qu'on désarme
dont on va regarder les mains de tous
les prisonniers au quai des bergues tous
te plaît c'est quoi ça moi j'en vois tu
tiens ton ton salut aux assassins
mouvement sarsgaard et voilà qu'à ses
dix côtes d'un coup qui est dans cette
cuisine c'est quoi ça ben on va taper
avec une pomme vraiment la porte
moi j'aimerais choper le taser du baïkal
taser aubin une mode rex plus correct ça
dégage
oui taser la marge ebit à saint géry
taser c'est lui qui l'a eu
et maintenant waouh
il vient ce débat et c'est génial cette
nouvelle arme excusez moi s'il vous
plaît pardon excusez moi je suis passé
voilà moi j'ai plus de vie et qu'avez
vous calmez vous annoncez vous tuer ils
sont bien avant sur moi j'aimerais juste
voir un petit peu où il ya quoi en fait
ça c'est les douches avec la fameuse
savonnette tétouan [ __ ] le premier
meurtre de l'histoire avec une
savonnette tellement millions pour cet
homme je me dis alors par la baille à
quoi j'ai vraiment tout analyser ce
qu'on peut pas trouver une arme dans des
dans des cellules non impossible n'ont
toujours pas aux dons je me suis pas toi
c'est comme un gros corps dégagés [ __ ]
ici au ne pas la prendre il ce média ou
tout seul ces genres sur mika ou tout
seul forcément une arme cachée ce pas
aussi passionné vous la dernière fois
dans le bureau du boss des vins sabres
bah je suis sûr c'est là au regard des
ja de garde on va essayer d'aller
là-haut là bas mon avis protège pas
cette cellule pour rien
envoyez je vous l'avais dit à part les
quelque 1 5 hectare c'était surtout pas
attendre pour le taser on va le taz et
hop là ça mais j'ai jamais vu un mec
résister à un coup de taser quoi mais
jamais vu un mec se faire raser tout
court or moi on va pas chercher à
comprendre à tous tu t'es allé en haut
où est le boss de la mafia qui s'il faut
un rôle à sa part sur l'agression tu
veux tuer cet homme c'est ça dans ton
n'est pas du coup je me suis un ami que
j'ai vu à trouver un du courrier de mon
côté où est le mec samouraï moi c'est
lui que je vais défoncer aulas et à tous
pour vos amis vous faites quoi vous non
mon ami s'est fait tuer je me casse j'ai
pas de courage et louise attaque
mais non mais non mais là où plus qu'à
casser de l'autre côté ok c'est là-bas
en fait attendait et ce que je pars pour
une main de voilà on va prendre une
barre ni vu ni connu
regardez il est en face le [ __ ] yakuza
c'est le chef de la prise aurait déjà
voilà allez dégagez
non il a eu le temps d'avoir au non plus
ils lèchent que tu étais en mon rang
c'était mon millions ok taser allez on
t'a tout ça dégage et l'a arrêté d'être
au loup mais non mais non mais non
comment est ce qu'on pourrait tuer le
boss de la mafia la [ __ ] dégage toi ça
c'est quoi
avec une cuisse de poulet moyens boude
pas faire ça fait zéro dégâts ici à quoi
oh c'est la salle des arts mec je
pouvais tout les olalalala est une arme
une armée là la cuisine y à rien mais
qui agite les vieux plats tout naze
assis là y'a un truc au tuyau le mec qui
fait de m génial
regardez-le au hockey parfait alors moi
j'ai trouvé ce qu'il faut faire
regardez il faut tout de suite aller
dans la salle de contrôle regardez là je
vais là j'ai ouvert des cellules à on
n'est jamais venu si ces cellules
d'isolement qu'on est ouverte
non c'est quoi ce droit ok le temps
s'est dégagé à tort et je me fais
breaker mais pourquoi tu applaudis
il se fait du côté des gardiens les mecs
si voulez vous a échappé de prison c'est
le pire truc à faire quoi mais c'est ses
portes là que je dois ouvrir je peux
ouvrir voir ca
mais y'a personne en isolement mais que
c'est complètement con y'en a qui est
mort ah non il en fait autant pour moi
on lui ces mecs de dôme est regardé il
fait de maître il est fâché on va
libérer va être content mon gars pour
nous tous et l'a logiquement alors la
mecque
il est de mon côté l'otan dégage toi
regardez maïdo m mais pourquoi pourquoi
mêler complètement mais je suis avec toi
mais pourquoi vous êtes courageux vous
l'hiver vous faites ça [ __ ] c'est pas
vrai la balle est à dire matériel se
tient le grand
le mec il m'a mis un coup de poing c'est
comme si je m'étais pris un poteau à 200
km/heure et ya pas de loyauté dans cette
prison là voilà tu appelles cet homme
qui m'attaquent sabourin lui toi je
t'aime beaucoup ici qu'on peut être amis
se plaît bien
tu es sur l épreuve énervé fdp
et si on savait ce qu'on veut faire de
la vie totalement pas allez on va ouvrir
viso le moment on a pu dû par contre
cholet attend le pc à pau il est où le
grand de deux mecs qui se la pète à
tient largement ce mec tu as trop levé
bâtard et rock et le recul est battu
avec un petit plateau pas confondre avec
petit bateau un des abonnés j'aimerais
bien qu'on reste en vie jusqu'à la fin
avril dans un raid à gré c'est mon ami
connard du coup lui c'est mon pote mais
souhaitions une seconde à chaque fois
c'est très regrettable
ah non il est amaigri et des bras mais à
quel gardien il attaque il me focus moi
ta sociaux moi qui pensais comme en
course c'était pareil il a dit lundi
aucune mon frère a buzzé le méthyle
ateba l'attend s'amuser même pas elle
fait reculer eh bien moi je rigole plus
maintenant prenez vrai voilà j'ai
championne je me suis enfui
ça dégage ça dégage ça dégage ça dégage
et la dernière balle ce sera pour
jean-michel de médecins quand il est là
regardez il est là il est là et il est
plus là stupeur
houda terre coup d'haltères on est dg
des mecs temps c'est l'homme à la
machette lui mais non mec mais qu'est ce
qu'il fout là à mes envies météo va
jamais s'en sortir
arrête arrête je m'y arrête hockey a tu
veux te bat avec les points je vous
envoie ce matin que les poils c'est bon
cette fois je regrette immédiatement il
résiste à notre outil quoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas faire des collatéral oh oui
voilà parfois père serre non j'ai oublié
que tu ralentis non pas à mon pape au
pardon j'ai pu de vie je vais mourir au
nom mais jean-michel machette arrête non
mais arrête
oui tu jean-michel machette alors avec
l'agression dans deux gourous une
seconde collatéral head shot jam achète
on à la machette de la prison maintenant
c'est moi le boss j'ai tué le boss les
mecs je suis le boss regardez j'ai tué
le boss dont je suis le nouveau boss
s'il vous plaît par respect ou à la
machine dans la magie délicate c'est
maintenant je suis à nouveau buzz monte
en d1 est ce que vous m'entendez l'homme
nu de la douche
il est là ok je libère la bête c'est la
fin c'est la fin voilà allez 25 kw à eux
voulaient battre a ajouté je suis
joubert
oui l agence ria fin de cette troisième
vidéo sur baltard loi n était pas aimé
ça vous a plu
moi j'ai vraiment pas aimé parce qu'à
padilla pas loyauté est et j'aime j'aime
pas ça j'ai vu un mec faire un discours
aussi bégayant alors ce sont allés dans
une prochaine news merci d'avoir regardé
si vous êtes passés nouvelle journée
défoulez vous sur ce jeu ça fait
vraiment du bien d'ailleurs même si la
journée a été bonne
ça fait quand même du bien allez entrer
dans une prochaine vidéo portez vous
bien chatroom plus
oh